welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Groot finally speaks in
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 or should
I say he was always speaking but we only
now started listening for the first time
Groot said something other than I am
Groot or we are Groot and that was the
voice of Vin Diesel kroken I love you
guys now while you might have heard this
is a violation of a cardinal rule for a
character James God is confirmed it was
actually an example of the audience
hearing what the characters hear there's
actually a lot that goes into this when
it comes to groot's biology in the
subtle ways language and sound are
conveyed in these films so I'm gonna
break all this down for you new rock
stars by the way is now a network of
three channels this main Channel my film
analysis Channel The Deep dive where I
re-broke down the whole Guardians
Trilogy also the Matrix and a video
where I made an AI version of myself
also the newly launched break room
Channel please subscribe to all three
and to support us grab something from
our merch store nerdright.shop like this
89013 shirt okay when the Guardians all
go their separate ways at the end of
volume three group surprises Us by
saying I love you guys and my Easter egg
breakdown that came out on release day I
think theorize that Groot wasn't
actually vocalizing this in the real
world that everyone could hear and that
anyone passing outside this bar would
have just heard the regular I am Groot
but instead what we were actually
hearing was what the Guardians who
understand groot's vocal utterances here
that after nine years we've spent enough
time with Groot to finally become
Guardians of the freaking Galaxy
ourselves and we are Groot James Gunn
was asked about this and a question that
was linked to a Gizmodo article that
shared the same Theory and got it
confirmed yes that's exactly what it
means this is a convention that we've
seen in media before in the 1990 Tom
Clancy filmed The Hunt for Red October
the camera pushes in on the mouth of a
guy speaking Russian with English
subtitles and then in the same shot it
just transitions into him speaking
English
foreign
and the seventh angel poured forth his
bowl into the air and the voice cried
out from Heaven saying ABC's last had an
episode with Saeed in a flashback
switching from Arabic to English in the
same line so that audiences wouldn't
have to read subtitles
and all the pain will stop
for Shiite friends have already
implicated you in the bombing Avatar the
way of water also used this convention
in the opening sequence when Jake Sully
explained how after a while hearing the
navi language became as common as
English to him his subtitles drifted
away and we just heard English from
there forward James Gunn was really the
first Marvel director to actually deal
with the way alien languages work in the
MCU in 2014's Guardians of the Galaxy he
established that Peter Quill had a
universal language implant that allowed
him to understand all known
interplanetary languages but that did
not apply to Groot as the Flora
colossi's speech wasn't registered as a
language in the index so when Peter
Quill was processed with Groot on the
Kiln he initially couldn't understand
him
well that's just as fascinating as the
first 89 times you told me that what is
wrong with Giving Tree here well he
don't know talking good like me and you
so his vocabulistics is limited to i and
m and Groot
exclusively in that order but over time
enough quality time with Groot allowed
the Guardians to become sensitive to his
sounds and understand the nuances of
what he's saying which is why Peter
could understand him the volume 2 post
credit scene you've got to clean up your
room it's a complete mess
I am Groot I am not boring you're boring
and all the Guardians were able to
understand Groot at this teenage age at
the beginning of infinity War Groot hey
and now in volume 3 since the Gamora of
this film is a Gamora from an alternate
timeline with no memories of Groot or
the others she's back to being unable to
understand groups I am Groot I know who
you are already that is until the end of
this movie when Gamora looks out over
nowhere and group comes up behind her to
say I am Groot and she responds thanks
just tell I'm gonna be right and then
she stops and realizes that she can
finally understand him he says I am
Groot again and she says yeah it was
good working with you too so shortly
after this when Groot tells the others I
love you guys James Gunn cuts to outside
the bar looking in at them through the
window it's his way of showing that we
only heard it that way seconds earlier
because we were just inside of the room
with them every other time in this movie
when we hear Groot speak it's outdoors
or in the company of others with less
time spent with groups we only hear I am
Groot in the opening scene on nowhere
where they're walking around eating
orloni Cosmo is present there and Cosmo
hasn't spent a whole lot of time with
Groot when Groot is in the company the
ravagers we only hear I am Groot a lot
of the other times Gamora is their
present with him when they arrive to
counter Earth and meet the Human animals
it's all I am Groot and then of course
everything on the highway evolutionary
ship only at the end of the movie when
we're in a closed room with just the
Guardians Groot has spent the most time
with do we hear him the way they do hey
kick bad habits to the curb let good
habits into your life and say hello to
fume bad habits are bad good habits are
good so why not just remove the bad from
your habit fume is an Innovative
award-dominated device that does just
that instead of electronics fume is
completely natural instead of vapor few
Muses flavored Air instead of harmful
chemicals fumum uses all natural
delicious flavors you get it instead of
bad fume is good it's a habit you're
free to enjoy and makes replacing your
bad habit easy Doom comes with an
adjustable airflow dial and is designed
with movable Parts magnets it's super
fidgety which is perfect for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your bad habit using a fume is like
having a breath of fresh minty air
coming out of a world-class fidget toy
that looks like it came from a schmancy
gift shot stopping the bad habit is
something we've all put off because it's
hard but switching to fume is easy over
100 000 people have used fume to
successfully break out of bad habits and
now you can too head to tryfume.com and
use code new rockstars to save ten
percent off when you get the journey
pack today that's try fum.com and use
code new rockstars to save an additional
10 off your order today you'll also
notice that it's not just an auditory
thing groot's mouth moves in the shape
of the words I love you guys so they
literally see his mouth form those words
yes you could say this is a bit of
magical realism but that is what
communication is it's our brains
including our optic and auditory nerves
processing information from another
source and puzzling it together in our
minds in a way that makes sense to us so
is the voice we hear coming out of any
loved one their own voice or just how
they sound to us inside our own minds an
expression of love is not just an
objective noise thrown out into the open
air for anyone else to grab it's an
intentional subjective message meant
specifically for another this
communication theme runs throughout the
film when you re-watch it closely gun is
particular about making all the music of
this movie diegetic coming from an audio
Source justified in the context of the
scene and groot's voice is no different
we hear everything the way characters do
and him saying I am Groot translating to
I love you guys is just another song
that these characters are all hearing
when the Guardians try to communicate in
their spacesuit to that one scene Peter
Quill struggles to communicate his love
solely to Gamora and through
technological accident communicates it
to the whole group when we meet the
Human animals on counter Earth and go
inside their home there are no subtitles
to that language the Guardians aren't
burdened to just try to communicate with
them with gestures and emotional context
as much as possible which also tells us
the high evolutionary designed these
beings to not be able to communicate
with anyone from the outside world I
mean he learned his lesson with 893 now
much has been made about groot's anatomy
and how fast he grew into swole group
and now King Groot or Alpha Groot in the
post credit scene a reminder that James
Gunn has confirmed that this group is
not a clone of the OG group who died
despite what all you botanists out there
say how plants grown from broken off
pieces of other plants should work nope
gun is confirmed this fruit was the
previous group's Offspring a different
being with different DNA and different
memories stop trying to correct him on
it he is a right director of the series
he gets the final say and so this group
has a different anatomical structure and
grows a lot more and I had theorized
before that it could be benefiting from
the photonic knowledge of other
Guardians like the more people he
communicates with the stronger he gets
and now in this post-credit scene that
includes Guardians with Juiced up Powers
Adam Warlock the telekinetic Cosmo and
freaking phyla who seems to have Cosmic
radiation and I believe now that the
reason we heard we are a Groot in the
2014 film was the same process of
characters within the scene hearing the
intent behind the words and not the
words themselves the Guardians were in
an enclosed space once more
understanding Groot has he communicated
something new to them if anyone outside
of that Branch cocoon with a near shot
was eavesdropping they probably would
have just heard a muffled I am Groot but
everyone within that sphere heard
groot's intent which was we are Groot he
could join us for a live show we're
doing in Los Angeles on Friday May 26th
tickets are in the description you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more for analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]